[Music]
hi I'm Dan Lavelle from the google play
developer operations team we get a lot
of questions from developers about app
visibility and search on Google Play
while we can't reveal every ingredient
in the secret sauce I want to cover some
tips to set you up for success the first
thing you should do is double check your
configuration to make sure your app is
visible to the right audience if it's
your first time publishing verify that
your app is published not in draft and
that it's available in the production
track and not just alpha or beta if you
previously pushed your apk to the alpha
or beta tracks click on that track then
click the move to prod button under
actions for the version that you want to
push to production remember it may take
a few hours to see your changes appear
on Google Play next check your apps
pricing and distribution page to make
sure that you've targeted all the
countries that you want to distribute to
click show options to verify you haven't
restricted distribution to any
particular wireless carrier lastly you
want to determine if your configuration
is excluding any devices from the apk
page under supported devices click
c-list to view the device compatibility
list by default you'll see supported
devices but you can also filter the list
to see devices that are unsupported by
your configuration or devices you've
manually excluded if your app isn't
showing up in search results for a
specific device consider its feature
requirements you can see a summary of
apk details by clicking on your apk
version number the API level screen
layout resolution and other feature
requirements can often exclude a user's
device automatically for example if your
app's minimum API level is 16 plus only
users of jelly bean and above will see
your app in search results when
searching Google Play on their device
get as much information as possible from
the user when looking into compatibility
issues and make sure you're not
unintentionally excluding that device to
your apps feature requirements it may
seem like a no-brainer to create a solid
app title and description but you want
to make sure that your title is focused
unique and avoids too many common words
your description should be thorough
however the full text will likely be
truncated under a read more button so
include what's most attractive and
valuable to users above the fold
also remember to follow Google Play
content policies when creating your
store listing getting more data about
user behavior can be critical to
improving your apps you can integrate
mobile app analytics from Google
Analytics to get insight about your user
behavior set up custom campaigns to
judge the effectiveness of external
marketing campaigns and get a better
understanding of your audience lastly
and most importantly you should aim to
deliver a high-quality and lasting
experience for users deliver regular
updates for your app and encourage users
to provide feedback and +1
recommendations on Google Play remember
to respond to customers that have had a
bad experience it could be the
difference in turning a one-star review
into five hopefully some of these tips
help you reach even more users though
you can always learn more the Google
Play Android developer Help Center until
next time I'm Dan Lavelle and this has
been play bytes